foreign
people what's up we were talking about
In and Out Burger what's your order put
it in the comments below um I've turned
into a two burgers no fries guy uh so if
you're not their fries are not very good
you gotta get them fried hard and I do
the protein Burger so I can have the
fried hard fries yeah the fries well
done I mean if I were a vegetarian
animal style fries would be the only
thing that gets me through uh this is
this is good this is a good start we're
talking about the last of us
um well if this is a show about enjoying
the simpler things um you know like
really appreciating what Society has to
offer like burgers and escalators
um or whatever they were freaking out
about that show uh which was really good
we're gonna talk about it today we're
going to watch Anna's trailer together
we'll do deleted scenes uh and we'll
talk take your comments and questions
and put those in the chat we'll respond
to them at the end of the episode and
then tease you with next week's honest
trailer which I'm still
watching through in chunks
because it is a visual Onslaught
um that that is maybe better broken up
but still a good experience overall yeah
I I without without spoiling too much
the same company that that produced this
this film that we're doing for next week
also produces a lot of TV shows and I
feel like they've got it they pack a
season's worth of TV plot into every
movie and like half a movie plot into
every season of Television such as the
entertainment industry it's a weird it
feels backwards now yeah you guys suck
for that this is a movie with a TV
season's worth of story going yeah but
this is your clue for next week so we'll
save the clue for the end of the episode
while we talk about this TV show that I
think um
look I didn't play through this game I'm
shocked because I love games but I did
not even bother with this one because it
doesn't look fun I know it's a good
story but like I say in the in the
trailer being the best video game
writers like being the best hand
musician and that was a clip that we
show of the four squeezins which I'm a
big fan of shout out to the four
squeezins yeah
yeah it's like that but if they could do
you know Ave Maria I always assume that
when they separated the boys and the
girls in class that's what they were
teaching you guys to do
us naturally yeah yeah
um so the last of us it's a really good
show uh it's very
um look
is it a little self-serious uh as these
zombie post-apocalyptic and HBO dramas
tend to be yes but I think it's a good
and are there a million shows about like
uh a lone wolf and perhaps a cub making
their way a desolate Wasteland yeah that
seems to be like a weird sub-genre but I
think look this is impeccably uh put
together especially when you uh dock it
but not docket points but like it has
the video game adaptation handicap again
I didn't play the game but I think that
this is just a good TV show I'd be happy
if they made this out of uh c-man or
whatever as we say evenly scene
um we're lucky we're very lucky that
this is what came out of that process
um and uh this is a good show what do
you guys think
yeah I loved it I mean I love Pedro
Pascal and basically everything
um he his ability to create that kind of
like chemistry I mean obviously it's
easier for him to do it now because uh
it's actually him and not like Clint
Eastwood's kid and an actual human girl
and not a puppet so I'm sure that it's a
lot easier for him to be able to like
find ways to like uh super uh connect
with Bella but them together is uh
really amazing and I love that it does
seem like he is trying very hard to be
his own Joel and not try to do the video
game because I think that's also a
really hard thing now that we have
actual actors doing the video games this
isn't it's not like the first Resident
Evil where it's like you know uh do you
have the key of unlocking or like
whatever that is and so these are actual
uh performances with people performing
dialogue so it can be kind of easy to
fall back into the familiar patterns of
the the lines but no he does a fantastic
job
and obviously like um what's his name uh
Craig Mason uh he do real good when he's
Bleak bigger the better yeah the Bleaker
the better yeah
it's it's a very tough balance they've
got to strike because if you you know I
feel like conventional wisdom with video
game adaptations is you can't you gotta
reference the game but you can't be too
slavish about it being a video game you
got to kind of do your own thing or else
it feels like that the Doom movie when
there's like the first person shooter uh
you mean the best part of the dude or
the other one that I always think of the
Silent Hill movie where they actually
have poor rod and Mitchell has to
basically like platform jump for a few
scenes like she's literally has to like
play A Silent Hill game and so you feel
like you know there's there's that stuff
like they've got to make it exactly like
the game and then there's the other side
where it's like no you've got to break
totally free of the game make it your
own thing and like you've got to kind of
service both of those ideas that it's
really hard to do and you get a lot
we've got a lot of examples like you
know the Assassin's Creed movie where
they kind of do neither one that well
and what I think druckman and mazzin do
here is they actually nail both examples
which is really like there are sequences
that are ripped right out of the game
that feel very cool and like an homage
and like they reinvented that part that
that sequence so you could really see it
as a TV show which is sort of like
exactly I think what what Taps into what
fans want but then they're also taking
big risks and they're painting way
outside the lines and we're seeing
characters from totally new we're seeing
new angles on Stories We already knew
and I mean to be able to come at this
from both of those perspectives and nail
both sides of it I think was the real
high wire act like they yeah that that
must have been tough to pull up yeah so
you know good stuff not too many
critiques uh coming out of us but uh let
us know what they got wrong and you
hated uh in the in the comments and
let's uh let's watch the Australia
that on the streaming trailer getting a
lot of work yeah from a showrunner who
hit his stride once he started being
unfunny on purpose and the world's best
video game writer and honor about his
prestigious as world's best hand
musician
[Music]
comes a nerdy IP about a grizzled father
there's so many covers
no the TV show
no the TV show based on the game
[Music]
the TV show based on the game that also
Stars Pedro Pascal
The Last of Us so pause I mean why is
this taken over
um pop culture not a pop culture but a
certain type of
adaptation of a something that has
slightly goofy or like low brow Source
material or something looked down on and
I think that gives it like is it because
it gives it a veneer of like grittiness
and groundedness to just do the old man
who's lost his his way and his sense of
feeling and he is just one little spark
in this adorable charge of his like make
some love again like I don't know is it
why is this so popular right now it's
such a genre thing and so I don't want
to necessarily be like uh you know it's
the Logan effect because and mostly
because like it Wolverine him hanging
out with like a 13 year old girl and
like teaching her the ropes while
cutting up people that's kind of always
been his gig that's been his Jam from
like the 80s
um yeah no I think that that is part of
it like it's an easy way to
um show the character development when
you're bouncing someone off like
literally the cutest or the cussiest
small person you can put them next to
both yeah or both yeah I think it also
Taps into like this is how a lot of
Americans like see themselves like I
think there is something to be said for
like there this idea of like the Lone
Wolf rugged individualist like tough guy
who's seen it all but like Still Still
somewhere deep down has like a heart of
gold and wants to like help help his
neighbor and be a good man but like oh
but he's been through so much he's so
rugged it's not like like a lot I've
worked in seven different Boost Mobile
stores
that just like it's not a coincidence
accidents that this is like the the
story about himself that like Travis
Bickel gets obsessed with and like this
is really deep into the American psyche
this idea and I think that a lot of
these shows kind of using tapping into
that idea which is already just out
there and archetypal for Americans but
doing it with a character like an IP it
there's a lot of power in that that it's
it's tapping into a story Americans
already like in a way that they see
themselves but with these characters
that they also really like and that are
meaningful for them when you could do it
I can hit it like Logan
I think it it has a lot of like innate
power yeah and I think this is also how
people think that they would be during
the apocalypse which like no thank you
yeah I'm good take me out first way oh
yeah first wave first wave for sure
right and it makes a difference make me
patient zero because it's nothing
there's an earthquake in L.A I'm like
it's not Bill we all recognize it like
it's not the Nick Offerman we all
recognize that we're not that guy we're
not the ultimate survivalist obsessive
weirdo who's got a Bunker full of like
canned beans waiting it out we're all
the Joel like we're gonna just adjust
right away like we're gonna learn it on
the job we're learning the apocalypse on
the job
figure this out like I'll I'll take care
of the dead bodies during the day for
money and then steal truck batteries at
night I'll be fine you all are in real
trouble but I'll figure it out
all right uh yeah trench and observation
as always uh all right keep going
flashback to 2003 when scientists
discovered a nasty fungus Among Us
turning anyone they bit into whatever
word we're using for zombies this time
no infected oh it was infected it's
crawled in with infected we've been near
infected there's no infected out here
the hell they're right leading to a
dystopia where no one got to see Return
of the King in theaters and gave the
best chance at survival to people with
made up gluten allergies
ingredient like flour now embark on a
nine hour escort Mission across the
desolate empty version of America known
as Canada that brings some of the game's
most iconic scenes to life
but strips out all the player choice I'm
sorry I have no other choice 90 of the
zombies you see it's empty Ed the
hilarious bugs
you can't even look at it it's like I'm
setting it focus on the central theme of
I will say that
a critique I saw uh levied at this a lot
was that like there's a there weren't
enough infected or it didn't seem there
weren't enough zombies in it of course
compared to the game because like wow
that game would be boring um but yeah
it's a game yeah I will say it
again having not played the game I do
sympathize with that because I didn't
feel like they were much of a threat
throughout the series I felt like this
was it was a very distant and remote and
like not tangible threat there were
moments when they were like you know
going through like a tunnel or something
and there was there was mushrooms uh
tendrils and stuff like that but seemed
like you could totally just like
amp you just you could just go you could
just go down the road and you know I
know man was the real monster and
everything but like the zombies didn't
seem like much of a person I think that
there is something cool about now that
we've had so many
zomb drums like the
post-apocalyptic monster genre is so
huge that I think stuff like this and
and station 11 have kind of had this
sort of interesting idea of like what if
we go beyond the first few years of the
Apocalypse when it's all about like how
am I going to survive day to day yeah
and like what like 20 years later 30
years later life would kind of return to
some semblance of normality even if
there were still monsters around every
once a while like and I get the critique
if you were just watching this is like I
want to watch a zombie show give me the
zombies like I don't think it's that it
is more like this look at the world
where
you know the zombies aren't the primary
threat they're like another thing that
exists in this world that you've got to
look out for like I don't know I think
that's kind of cool I do get it that if
you're watching it as a zombie action
horror show it's a little bit like when
are they gonna get it to the fungus
Factory right which is and for me I
don't like jump scares and I think that
I appreciate that there aren't nearly as
many in this as you would think because
it is like a zombie property I wouldn't
want to watch Nine episodes where
there's like five jump scares every
episode I think that that would get
really tiring I think it would take away
from the bigger narrative totally yeah
that's fair
um so look at that uh the opinions all
around and they're all fine uh let's
keep going Stay With Me Now what if the
real monster was man all along you can't
stick too close to the source material
though that's how you get a house of the
dead movie it is
with more trauma then you can shake a
dead kid at
played by Pedro Pascal an actor
currently traumatized by a never-ending
horde of daddy comments if the whole
vibe of the doubt are you new to it I'm
a little it's been going on for years
that's what I mean
you're a happy family and think he's my
cool [__] father yep I would love if
you could read a few thirsts no
leave him alone it's becoming a problem
it is becoming a problem
there's related to sexual harassment now
guys yeah there should be some type of
um quota or something on how many times
like the talk shows start getting the
junket circuit can do the same bit I
feel like like maybe there's a drawing
if everybody wants to do the read the
read the first tweets thing five Outlets
get to do it and then you like then you
then you close the gate like a lotto
toss him a sharp stick like in Batman uh
like in a dark night and just make them
fight it out it's like yeah if you want
to do the zaddy bit you got to take out
everybody else yeah I feel like every
celebrity should get one non-controversy
non-scandal like get out of this bit
free card you know like like not like if
you're accused of doing something bad
everybody's allowed to ask you about it
forget it but like Leonardo DiCaprio
should have a like I don't want to talk
about the Titanic door anymore and if
somebody brings it up they can just be
like no I'm sorry we're not gonna play I
gotta get out of this [__] card I'm
sorry we're not it could be like a punch
card like fine I'll do it but like you
have to put a stamp on this card right
it's full I don't do it in Hollywood
you've only got three left and then you
could never ask me about being a zaddy
again so like the Jimmy's are just gonna
have to figure it out for themselves
right yeah like something something just
because I I that's enough already like
yes listen he's a very attractive man I
don't think any frequently cast as a
father I don't think any of us are
denying he's a good-looking dude
let's say and I mean in I think in real
life he can pull this off but they
really you know rough up Joel quite a
bit and there's a moment where he's like
I'm 36.
yeah okay uh no sense
in the future
uh yeah I think Pedro could pass but but
Joel was Joel was looking like a hard a
hard 36 years
all right keep going need someone to
begrudgingly smuggle a minor across
state lines for non-consensual surgery
but he'll soften once he meets Ellie a
girl whose brainstem can cure the few
sad creeps Left Alive in this Hell's
Gate she's your everyday gun booze and
porn loving American
well what just to warm up
around that thing please get rid of it
who could really use a father figure if
only to tell her that saying every 10
seconds doesn't make you sound mature
[Music]
what the [__]
thank you Kevin for organizing these yes
she really tells a story
I did not realize you must have missed
all the street signs in the enormous
Forest holy
uh I thought Bella Ramsey was incredible
um really really good start to her
career after uh Game of Thrones and then
this and it to the point where I was
like okay I'm gonna make a like a
montage of all the like forced fake
laughing that Bella had to do for the
dumb pun jokes and I went back and it's
like no she's actually acting like she
thinks it's funny and like and I was
convinced that she actually found these
things funny just by based on her
performance because I just assumed she'd
have to be like and like not be able to
pull it off but no she sold me that she
liked puns yeah for me it was definitely
the combined Glee uh this pun is like
fun and stupid and a dad joke and also
I'm really pissing off Joel like she
really sold being able to take joy in
both of those because she was I mean if
you're a kid you're gonna annoy the
nearest adult
was dropping Joel was dropping puns to
his daughter in episode one so they're
they're character building puns you know
this is they're the puns are telling the
story
um yeah powerful stuff yeah they're
load-bearing okay
saddle up together and learn a valuable
lesson that the real zombie cure was the
friends they made along the way like
Tess Joe's ride or die until she did
both
Bill and Frank the couple who lived
through the true horror of spending 16
years alone with your significant other
man you say Resource Management so help
me I will run through one of your
tripwires that's also means it was up to
10.
before dying in the least gamer way
possible
then there's Henry and Sam brothers from
Kansas City who
all right Riley the girl who first
inspires Ellie's
Marlene or see McCord's face
well they really are the last of us you
know HBO means business when they kill
off a nepo baby in the first episode
even in the family
um I guess just a shout out to uh to the
bill and Frank episode I mean Bravo
great great one off there
um HBO no that's not HBO I think like it
was Andor that did the Andy Circus
um you know uh three episode Arc
diversion and I love it when shows are
able to do that things can go like
semi-epasonic but still tell a a through
line that kind of moves it along and
like man we've been we've been blessed
we've been blessed this year I think
that was like the the number one best
idea they had going into this like as a
way to sort of tackle last of us as a
show was like it doesn't always have to
be Joel and Ellie like you can give it
this kind of yep
episodic like as they're going on their
Journey they're meeting these people and
then we can kind of Branch up and see
those stories like that I I feel like
another creative team might have put the
kibosh on that like nope audiences are
going to want to see it's the Joel and
Ellie show and there are characters we
gotta stick with them I think that was
such a smart idea to like Branch it out
and like you could take an episode where
Ellie's there but we're gonna really
focus on this other community that she's
meeting up with and it doesn't I think
it lets them
yeah I was just about to say it because
the second game is out and I don't know
if it's going to be like where the
second game is going to be all of the
second season but that's it that's what
we got you know they've said they're
then they're gonna take the second game
and probably break it into two more
seasons yeah but then that might be no I
mean no need to like keep this going
forever but that does let them you know
broaden the scope of what's otherwise
yeah I think I think we're right now
looking at it's probably like a three
maybe four if they come up with a big
grandiose big fit by me and I think if
they're if they're open to it they
should go the other way and do the bill
and Frank game where it is like Resource
Management kind of like a Clash of Clans
thing like you have to maintain your
your little domiciles like Plants versus
Zombies like Plants versus Zombies and
you've got to have your stuff ready to
go yeah oh let's see but it's like
eating Sim at night there's like a day
night cycle where it's like first you
fend off you guys are just describing
stardew Valley you're describing yeah
zombies if you get to the mystical part
of it there are zombies so it's just
stardew Valley
I made it like I'm wearing that crop
cycle in and I'm like this is just work
um they're just planting a no one
okay keep going wake up a few decently
reviewed profitable game adaptations get
ready for a whole lot more of them and
enjoy the ride Gamers because now you
get to spoil what's going to happen
without having to read a book as Last of
Us pushes the relentlessly Bleak zombie
genre to its absolute limits kids die
Henry
they die all the time we're the only way
to keep your sanity is to take joy in
The Simple Pleasures
or failing that he gotta laugh for some
stale unfunny puns people are making
apocalypse jokes like there's no
tomorrow
[Music]
too soon no it's topical I stayed up all
night wondering where the sun went and
then it dawned on me why did the
Scarecrow get an award
because he was outstanding in his field
you dick a series relying on puns is a
key source of humor I can't even imagine
being part of something like that
story
zaddy daycare how Bella got her rude
back I Kissed A shroom and I hate it
Luigi Nick offers man A Home of all the
treples and all the compounds in the
world he falls into mine stop
collaborate and listen full metal Yellow
Jacket Mall Walker now eat this bread
for it is the body of Christ and eat
this meat for it is the body of George
Joel and Ellie Prime where's the cake
come on man let's get this one tomorrow
the cake is a lie it would have been an
effect gamer tactics how do I play Smash
the buttons Jordan Peterson when his
pill bottle has a childproof cap not
today
fast travel well how about that made it
in five days easy days absolutely
chowing down
what am I even eating that is 20 year
old Chef Boyardee ravioli knock out good
I actually agreed
thank you
what the [__] really bad wakeups
[Music]
bad place to wake up
eyes on me
fireflies
took most of the night
I'm exhausted God damn it and serious
abdomen injuries move your hand baby
we gotta get you inside no no no oh
y'all talk it through but please
remember that I'm bleeding out
sometimes yeah that was like six
different sequences where where people
were dealing with getting hurt right in
the ab and weird mom you were talking
about it why why it is that way it's I
think it's a it's a it's a little bit of
a convenient screenwriter thing because
it's like you're not if you take a like
to the face you're unconscious or you're
dead yeah like AB you could get hit in
the stomach and it's like that's serious
like you're not gonna just walk it off
like it's John Wicked right if it's the
shoulder then it's like no one's really
worried yeah I mean like you could just
walk
but like the ab is okay they're gonna
this is gonna take them out for a while
but they're not dead right away they
could still talk and be part of the
scene and be like even like the Nick
offer like no no I'm fine leave me I'm
gonna fight through it you know like
you've still got options after that
happened yeah I think I think that's why
you see a lot of dramatic uh stomach
injuries it's the most cinematic place
to get wounded because it gives you
plenty of time for like a death speech
or you or to get rescued but it's like
bad enough that like you can be kind of
out of breath and like I'm not gonna
make it you're putting it in payroll
back on the scene like now there's
tension because we got to get you out of
here because you're gonna you're gonna
bleed out exactly like Marlene said we
all know you take an injury to the
stomach eventually you will bleed out
yeah which is because like half of blood
right oh you get the coffee blood yeah
you get to like shake and do the like
like you get to do that stuff which is
fun
uh I'm just imagining that for the uh
the guy who gets shot in the dick by
RoboCop which is him and his buddies
like I'm gonna make it it's okay leave
me save yourselves I found the tip we'll
get you good
uh all right finish the finish all
cutscenes 4K
hey I think someone set the series on
easy mode these actors AI is way off
pretty easy
I could do that
hey that that one like if you're just in
an open snowy field you hear the crunch
you're you're gonna hear a big guy
running up on you yeah you're gonna hear
that crunch he's not that light on his
feet he's recovering from an AB wound
and they know that because there's
another scene where where uh I think
it's even the same episode where Ellie
sneaks up on David and he reacts he's
like wow you are a good little Hunter I
didn't hear you walk up at all but she'd
have the time to carefully sneak up on
him yeah Joel's running at Full Tilt
you'd hear a big guy running at you
I also noticed in episode one this is
true that they did have a box Trolls DVD
on their wreck which did not come out in
2003. hope somebody got fired for that
blunder
um but uh you the audience have not been
fired for that blunder thank you for
watching um like And subscribe and hit
the Bell so you don't miss another uh
thing another Ding-A-Ling um like these
outtakes roll them
in 2023 the world has beset by a deadly
plague the rise of fascism and crumbling
infrastructure
also the last of his TV show came out
story
last Mando standing not a fun guy likes
father likes puns Girl Meets World Vine
Hunter Tess your might classic original
recipe Marlene fed Dead Redemption host
writer Ron swansong killed by Bill the
brother shroom The Brothers Grimm Love
death and Mall Rats
The Hunger Games catching fireflies nine
hours of unskippable cutscenes
won't you take me to fungi town
with the success of this maybe they'll
finally dead my favorite game Seaman
well I think it's good that you're
exercising a little Caution about your
internet use
fire is a wonderful thing but I wouldn't
want to sit on a sofa made out of it
yeah rip Dreamcast uh you're saying you
used to play c-man a lot yes I did I I
did I used to work at a game place we
played everything I used to sell video
games at a uh it was a story that came
before GameStop bought everything but
yeah yeah and then you you have to talk
to it right it was like a Tamagotchi uh
yeah yeah there was like a uh because
the Dreamcast was like way ahead of its
time for everything and so yeah there
was like a voice
um thing that was in the rumble pack for
the for the Dreamcast controller and
yeah you would like talk to it and if
you didn't yeah he got like he's like
where have you been like all creepy and
[__] he was chat
gpt4s yes beautiful thing well coming
soon to uh stars do we need human rights
for semen is he self-aware but
c-man convinced me to leave my wife for
c-man
c-man fell in love with me and I love
them back
um all right on to your questions uh MJ
Prince are leading us off um and also
I'll group in some similar questions Pat
magana too uh the D movie's not bad
apparently the Mario Bros movie is
promising
um are we finally in the Era of Good
Game adaptations and Pat magana adding
on do we think the Amazon God of War
show will be any good
you know I can't even I don't even start
judging the shows until I start until I
get a chance to like see a pilot because
I've been fooled before what's like that
looks really cool and it's really
promising and then you go in and it's
like oh this wasn't necessarily for me
so I've been trying to like I definitely
want to watch it it looks cool
um but the Pilot's gonna let me know if
it's gonna be like something I'm going
to want to spend you know 10 hours on
you know like the video game adaptation
curse thing is sort of generally
overblown at this point like obviously
there have been a lot of bad ones and
stink goes we we've mentioned a few
already on ghosts on this very show but
uh but I mean the Mortal Kombat 95 movie
was pretty cool I was very fan of that
back in the day and we've talked about
Street Fighter on this program I think
that's kind of a fun movie as well
the Sonic the Hedgehog movie a few years
ago people liked it I mean I feel like
at this point we've had a few already
that have come out and that there's no
reason to think a video game inspired
movie or TV show isn't necessarily going
to be yeah it was just so much better at
adapting now everyone's great at
adapting properties now and
understanding how to then you get Halo
and then you get Uncharted Rampage and
stuff like that very Loosely page is not
that bad even but hey hey yeah Halo is
Halo it's always a great example of what
we were or what I was talking about at
the beginning where it's like you you
you've got to find that balance you want
to go somewhat on your own and do some
new stuff but you can't have Master
Chief take off this helmet and start
dating aliens right away that's too far
like that's not you know like it's Gotta
you can't you can't you gotta you gotta
paint within the lines in some in some
way yeah
yeah they're here I I want to see Master
Chiefs love uh love nest that was what I
wanted that's what I came into Halo for
there's like three sequences from the
entire HALO Series where you're like
okay that sort of feels like a hail okay
everything else was just them going
broke it'd be like okay would buy lives
in an asteroid like that's not from like
I I play that Dating Game I'd play that
dating Sim
uh Pericles dragon balls with a fun fact
Arnold Schwarzenegger has a clause in
his contract that states he can
automatically end an interview if they
ask about Hercules in New York damn mama
I feel like every actor deserves their
ones in New York good job kids yeah it'd
be like asking him about getting to the
chopper or something
um and then let's end with uh this this
might take a minute but let's end with a
um an impromptu sju actually there's two
good sju topics so Louis Valenzuela
asked us to react to the Blue Beetle
trailer spider-verse trailer and
live-action Moana please oh my gosh okay
I haven't seen the the spider-verse one
yet is it I mean I'm sure it's great
um
uh Blue Beetle I am very torn on it
looks like fun uh like a like a fun uh
why a version of a superhero movie and
I'm sure it'll be entertaining but I
just I just can't I just can't get
excited for anything right now like that
um it looks cool I enjoy the character
I'm a little I I feel like I've seen
this movie
a bunch but I'm you know I'll probably
go see it it does look really cute it
seems incredibly Charming but I can see
for people like I don't want to be like
oh it's comic book fatigue but I could
definitely see where people like look I
just I don't know if I have it in me to
learn who blue pants gurgle balls yeah
big bad Beetleborg is yeah yeah I just
don't have it like it looks like every
little I get it he's a teen uh a bug
hits him and now he's got a alien bug
Powers I feel like I've seen the family
that like it's and I know they're
different but I can see from the outside
why you'd be like ugh I I totally agree
with you guys I I get everything you say
it just it sucks because it's not even
DC's fault like they didn't they're not
the ones who overdid this to death over
the last decade that was really Marvel
who's more done this to death but like
we're all worn out anyway I I feel like
this looks a lot like Ms Marvel and that
it is kind of DC's version of that sort
of same story so they're allowed like
this feels very appropriate to what a
Jaime Reyes Blue Beetle movie would be
yeah I just feel like yeah we've just
we've seen that movie a bunch of times
and so this is like another one of those
but I do think it looks like a good a
good version like family friendly-ish
superhero origin story yeah this stuff
was funny and
excited to check it out it's just yeah
we've seen a lot of this kind of coming
of age in superhero story at this point
you've seen it all good yeah I'm sorry I
understand it must be pretty good
because it was originally supposed to be
on streaming and then they decided to
put it in theaters which is nice right
it's it's like the anti-bat it's like
the opposite of that rest in peace this
one got promoted what the liquor
let's hit let's hear it for uh the rock
um bouncing back from Black Adam no no
no no okay Dwayne no from Daniel no I'm
sorry you don't get to double dip before
it's even been a decade the hierarchy of
Disney Disney Infinity
no no I'm sorry Dwayne and you don't get
to bring your kids and talk about how
awesome your Island and your dad is to
try to convince us not to make fun of
this big-headed stuff that you just
pulled I'm sorry I'm not that angry I'm
still coming off of some WrestleMania
rage
um but no Dwayne Dwayne no it hasn't
even been a decade and he's just moving
to Maui and to save us all the trouble I
don't care nearly as much as I'm saying
I really am getting rid of some
WrestleMania outrage right now I haven't
had a chance to podcast about it yet I I
feel like Dwayne a few years ago was
kind of in that he had like this moment
where it's like he could have gone back
to like bread and butter like make a
couple like hardcore action movies like
make something that you're you're old
school fans are really going to want to
see or
go a hundred percent into the
Nickelodeon Kids Choice Awards you know
domain and just live there forever and I
think yeah he saw the check yeah I think
we've seen where where the decision went
and it's not it's not the Dwayne that I
would love to see but the kids do love
him and I guess if he's gonna just
Embrace that and he'll be like their
their favorite like yeah there's another
decade of projects he can make in that
world I'm sure is there a way you think
that Maui will be able to get Tara mono
in the movie or no we're not gonna see
We're not gonna go to like Maui's boat
and he's got like a bar with all of his
own and we just cut to moana's parents
like mid Adventure they're just hanging
out doing their own thing
it's Tara tyronea Tara Maya whatever
yeah
like yeah yeah they'll definitely be
sipping on that at like some bar
um yeah look it's this isn't going to
come out for a while right like this no
they're just starting oh this is the
announcement so why why tell us that
this is coming so soon wait who is this
for like who is this announcement oh boy
no like this was come on this was for
Disney shareholders this was Bob Iger
Bob iger's first meeting with
shareholders since coming back to Disney
in November and that's where Iger
introduced this from stage like this was
100 Bob needs a big thing to go out
there and announce together yeah Q4 2026
or something like we've got a hit you
pencil
get them marking out you know like
that's that's 100 what this was and it
doesn't hurt that now this is the
conversation about Dwayne and not all of
the his like weird Machiavellian oh yeah
uh politicking behind the scenes give
the end credit scene to Zach Levi give
him some justice
yeah Wayne was happy to change the
conversation from Shazam to Bob needed a
big thing to juice from the from the
stage so if it makes logical sense
because the only other thing that came
out of that Iger shareholder thing was
like he's willing to license characters
there was a thing he talked about you
know like they're very protective of
their core Brands but he wouldn't
definitely say no to licensing
characters to other Studios for
third-party things and like that's a
shift in Disney but they didn't really
have anything else super exciting for
him to announce so I think that's what
the Moana knew totally easy to put that
that promo together you know yeah right
yeah and it's like a thing that's going
to grab headlines everywhere be like I
announced they're doing a live-action
Moana yeah crazy I think we need to do
like an auxiliary sju because like the
the Marvel cutbacks the the Harry Potter
uh series coming out maybe do an
emergency special yeah there's breaking
news breaking news but we're here
extensively talking about the last of us
and we're done with that because there's
not much to say except it's good um but
next week we'll be back uh soaking wet
and ready to go for next week
oh I do I do too but I just think
there's there's a lot to chew on there's
a lot of meat on that whale
I never knew my eyes could perceive
never mind all right I'll put that in a
drink yeah so we'll be back next time I
think you might be able to guess what it
is but thanks for sticking with us this
long and we'll be back then for
Australia commentaries have a good one
bye-bye
[Music]
thank you